Guten Tag, mein Name ist Yusuf Sechkin. Ich bin heute der zuständige Arzt für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, suggeren Sie bitte nicht, mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Josef Meister.
Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
J-O-S-E-F-Josef
F-A-I-S-T-I-R Meister
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Meister?
Ich bin 72 Jahre alt, Herr Doktor.
Ihr Gebustdatum bitte?
31. Dezember 1953
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1 Meter 78.
Ihr Gewicht bitte?
59 Kilogramm
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, natürlich. Mein Hausarzt heisst Herr Doktor Müller.
Was fühlt Sie heute so, Herr Meister?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe Rückenschmerzen seit 3 oder 5 Monaten.
Seit 3 oder 4 Monaten?
Ja, ungefähr seit 5 Monaten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Am Anfang waren es 3 oder 4, aber momentan 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6.
Hätten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, ich hatte keinen Unfall, Herr Doktor.
Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Mein Unterrücken.
Links oder rechts?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, ganz Rückenschmerzen habe ich.
Lendenbereich, oder?
Nein, ich bin nicht sicher, aber ich fühle mich im ganz rückenden Bereich.
Aber unten?
Ja, unten.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen bitte genauer beschreiben?
Stichend oder ziehend?
Ja, drückend und stichend.
Aber wissen Sie, Doktor, ich habe auch eine Wasserlastenprobleme.
Ich muss vielmals besonders nachts auf die Toilette gehen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Seit 3 Monaten.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, ja.
Das brennende Wasserlassen, oder?
Ich habe brennende Wasserlassen und ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Haar nicht leer ist nach dem Wasserlassen. Ich fühle es.
Sie können Ihre Wasserlassen nicht entleeren können, oder?
Ja, Sie haben Recht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass meine Blase nach dem Wasserlassen nicht leer ist.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Besonders nachts, 3-5 Mal.
Tagsüber?
Ja, ja, tagsüber, aber besonders nachts.
Ja, ja, tagsüber, wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Ungefähr 8 oder 10.
Ungefähr 10?
Ja, es ist sehr weich, Doktor.
Einmal 6, manchmal 8, manchmal 10.
Wie sieht Ihr Urin aus?
Dunkel.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht Fieber, Doktor. Aber ja, ich fühle mich ein bisschen fieberig, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost, Nachschweiß?
Ich habe keine Nachschweiß, aber Schüttelfrost, aber ja, ich habe Nachschweiß, Sie haben Recht.
Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, ich habe nicht Schmerzen, ich habe immer ganz rücken Bereich Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Schmerzen im Leistenbereich?
Ich habe nicht Schmerzen, Doktor. Nein, ich habe rücken Schmerzen.
Richtig. Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Ja, ich habe viele Medikamente in meinem Hausarzt gewessen.
Sie haben die Schmerzen?
Ja, sie haben die Schmerzen, viele Medikamente seit 6 Monaten.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, sie sind normal, sie empfehlen mir viel Wasser zu trinken.
Nehmen Sie keine Medikamente?
Nicht wirklich empfehlen, aber habe ich viele Mal 800 mg angenommen.
Aber es würde mir ein bisschen geholfen, Herr Doktor.
Richtig.
Aber ich habe diese Medikamente nicht regelmäßig angenommen, sehr bedrückt.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine feste Diagnose gestellt?
Nein, mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich alt bin, es ist normal.
Wurde bei Ihnen ein Ultraschall des Abdomens durchgeführt?
Ich hatte eine Anbietung von meinem Hausarzt, aber es ist mir gesagt, es ist normal.
Richtig. Hatten Sie das schon mal, die Endnische 5 werden?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, seit jetzt oder früher?
Vorher.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, vor drei Monaten.
Ja, ja.
Wann war die letzte 5 werden?
Ich habe gesagt, Herr Doktor, ich habe diese Medikamente immer seit 3 Monaten immer wasserlassen Probleme.
Aber vor 3 Monaten haben Sie keine Beschwerden über diese Thema?
Ja, ja, sie haben Recht.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich oder allmählich aufgetreten?
Anfangs war es plötzlich, aber in der Zeit ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Gibt es irgendetwas, das die Schmerzen schlimmer oder besser macht?
Schmerzen oder wasserlassen?
Beide.
Wenn ich bei mir bin, ist es nicht so schlimm geworden.
Aber mit dem wasserlassen habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Irgendwie ist es so, dass ich körperlich bin.
Richtig.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ist Ihnen Herzgasen oder Herzstolpe aufgefallen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Hautverfarbung bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Richtig.
Haben Sie Schwellungen in irgendwelchen Körperregionen bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ist das Bein geschwollen oder ist Ihr Bauch geschwollen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor. Es ist normal.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ich habe gesagt, Herr Doktor, ich muss dreimal nachtlich wasserlassen.
Deswegen habe ich Schlafprobleme.
Haben Sie Durchschlafstörungen, oder?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Meister?
Normalerweise gut.
Ich meine seit drei Monaten.
Nein, nein. Ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Ich habe keine Appetitprobleme.
Richtig. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, Herr Doktor, leider. Ich habe seit sechs Monaten 6 Kilo abgenommen.
Seit sechs Monaten?
Ja.
5 Kilo.
Herr Meister.
Herr Doktor, ich habe viele Angst. Mein Vater, mein Vater vor fünf Jahren an Prostatkarsinoma gestorben.
Mein sehr beileid, Herr Meister.
Deswegen keine Sorgen. Krebs ist am schlimmsten. Bitte denken Sie am Anfang nicht am schlimmsten, Herr Meister.
Okay.
Wegen Prostatkarsinoma vor fünf Jahren.
Wie alt war er?
Er war fünfundsechs Jahre alt. Nein, nein, fünfundachs Jahre alt.
Fünfundsechs Jahre alt. Ja.
Haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen, Herr Meister?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck seit zehn Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme 5 Milligramm Delix einmal morgens täglich ein.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe chronische Lungenentzündung, Herr Doktor.
Chronische Lungenentzündung. Seit wann haben Sie das?
Es ist so lange, ungefähr 20 Jahre oder 25 Jahre.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich benutze einen Spray, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der Name ist.
Ein Spray. Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen, Herr Meister?
Das war es.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich nehme Delix.
Außer Delix und Spray?
Ja, ich habe bei der Ibuprofen eingenommen. Ja, ich habe gesagt, aber das war es.
Ibuprofen. Wegen aktueller Beschwerde?
Ja, ja.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich habe nie operiert, nein.
Gut. Haben Sie Allergien oder Unfertigkeiten?
Ich habe keine Allergien oder Unfertigkeiten, Doktor.
Gut. Und rauchen Sie, Herr Meister?
Ja, ich rauche, aber ich denke nicht viel.
Ich rauche seit 40 Jahren zwei Schachteln Zigaretten.
Seit 40 Jahren zwei Schachteln.
Ja, es ist viel, Doktor, ist es viel?
Natürlich, es ist zu viel, Herr Meister.
Das ist gefährlich für Ihre Gefecht.
Aber ich liebe Rauchen, ja.
Ich verstehe, aber ich empfehle Ihnen mit dem Rauchen so schnell wie möglich aufzuhören.
Okay, okay. Verstehe.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich momentan?
Zwei Schachteln.
Zwei Schachteln, ja.
Füllen Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich. Zwei oder drei Mal pro Woche.
Ein Glas Wein oder ein Glas, ein Flasche Bier.
Zwei bis drei Mal?
Ja, pro Woche, ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich. Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Was ist Drogen, Doktor?
Marihuana, Haschisch.
Ah, ja nein, nein. Ich habe keine Drogen probiert.
Gut, ich freu mich.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport, Herr Meister?
Ja Doktor, ich bin so müde und ich möchte Sport treiben, aber ich bin so müde und ich treibe keinen Sport.
Sie sind müde?
Ja, ja.
Seit wann fühlen Sie sich müde?
Seit drei Monaten.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wie wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne mit meiner Frau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja.
Gut. Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Meister?
Ich bin Rentner. Ich bin 92 Jahre alt, Herr Doktor.
Was waren Sie vom Beruf?
Ich habe als Taxifahrer gearbeitet.
Das war ein stressiger Beruf, oder?
Ja, ich hatte viel Stress.
Verstehe.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihr Vater an Prostatkarsinom verstorben ist.
Ja.
Meine Mutter ist 65 Jahre alt und hat an Magentarsinom verstorben, Doktor.
Tut mir leid zu hören.
Haben Sie beide noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankungen, Bluthochdruck, Erhöhung?
Meine Mutter hatte Zuckerkrankungen und mein Vater hatte Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Geschwister, aber ich habe keinen Kontakt.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich bin immer in Deutschland.
Alles klar, Herr Meister.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe viele Fragen. Was habe ich?
Es ist zu früh, etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Meister.
Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich eine operative Diagnostik veranlassen.
Mit den Ergebnissen können wir entscheiden.
Eine Frage. Haben Sie Blut im Urin?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, mein Urin war dunkel, aber ich habe keinen Angriff, dass Blut da andere ist.
Bleiben Sie hier bitte. Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Okay, ich warte auf Sie, Doktor. Danke schön.
Danke, Herr Meister.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, gerne.
Ich bin Josef Meister, ein 72-jähriger Patient, geboren am 31.11.1953.
Er war 1,78 Meter groß und 59 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor Aufgrund.
Seit drei bis vier Monaten bestehender, druckender, zunehmender,
plötzlich aufgetretener, drückender Schmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde am Anfang mit drei, momentan mit fünf bis sechs von zehn bewertet.
Er hatte keinen Unfall.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen war er oftmals beim Hausarzt.
Er hat dagegen 800 Ibuprofen genommen.
Aber es hat ihm ein bisschen geholfen.
Als Begleitsymptomen gab er an, diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal zu haben.
Er geht am Nacht 3 bis 5 Mal zur Toilette, tagsüber 10 Mal.
Die Fragen nach Atemnot, Dyspnoe, Husten, Tachikalie, Hautverfabung, Oedema wurden verleint.
In der vegetativen Anamnese sind folgende Beschwerden bekannt.
Gewichtabnahme seit sechs Monaten, 10 Kilogramm Nikturi, Insomni wegen der Nikturi und Fieber.
Er fühlt sich fiebrig, so wie Nachtschweiß.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit zehn Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er Delix 5 mg Morgens ein.
Seit 20 Jahren leidet er an COPD.
Dagegen nimmt er Spray ein.
Der Name der Spray ist nicht erinnerlich.
Er ist noch nie operiert.
Es sind keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er ist Raucher.
Seit 40 Jahren raucht er zwei Schachteln Zigaretten täglich.
Das sind 80 Packages.
Er trinkt 2 bis 3 Mal in einer Woche Bier oder Wein.
Drogenkonsum wurde verleint.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er lebt mit seiner Ehefrau zusammen.
Er hat drei gesunde Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich Diabetes mellitus bei der Mutter.
Die Mutter ist mit 65 Jahren an Magenkarsinom verstoben.
Arterielle Hypertonie bei meinem Vater.
Der Vater ist mit 89 Jahren an Prostatkarsinom verstoben.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstheatose lautet auf Prostatkarsinom.
Er leidet seit 3 bis 4 Monaten an Rückenschmerzen.
Er hat Polio.
Er hat innerhalb von 6 Monaten 10 kg Gewicht abgenommen.
Die Differenz ist die Vertikulitis.
Ich bin mit dem Magenkarsinom in der Vergrößerung von Prostaten.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Zuerst würde ich die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und auskultieren.
Bei der Prostatkarsinomfaltpatient achte ich auf Abwehrspannung, Druckschmerzen,
Loslassschmerzen und mögliche Organomegalien.
Bei der Inspektion beurteile ich den Allgemeinen Zustand des Patienten und die Hautfarbe des Patienten.
Zu weiteren Abklärungen werde ich Labouruntersuchungen durchführen,
um das Blutbild, die Entzündungswerte, Leber- und Nierenwerte, PCA-Werte zu bestimmen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich auch eine digitale, rektale Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der digitalen, rektalen Untersuchung können wir Prostatengewebe überprüfen.
Wenn ein Tumor es gibt, können wir den Tumor erkennen.
Im nächsten Schritt würde ich eine operative Diagnostik durchführen.
Als operative Diagnostik werde ich den Ultraschall des Abdomens, Ultraschall des Prostats überprüfen oder durchführen.
Danach werde ich den CT des Abdomens durchführen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Zunächst werde ich einen Venöse-Zugang legen, um eine Venöse-Therapie zu ermöglichen.
Ich werde eine urologische Konstruktion veranlassen, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Danke für diese Information. Hat der Patient Hematomie?
Er beschreibt dunkle Urin. Ich habe es ihm gefragt, ob sie Blut im Urin bemerkt haben. Er sagte nur dunkle Urin.
Sie haben gesagt, dass der Patient mehrere Mal eine Hausarztin besucht hat.
Hat der Patient eine bekannte Krankheit?
Bisher wurde keine feste Diagnose gestellt. Sein Hausarzt hat ihm gesagt, sie seien alte Menschen. Das ist ganz normal.
Ganz normal. Aber jetzt hat der Patient Fieber, Dysurie, Polokurie und manchmal Hematomie.
Er hat eine Prostatik mit Systeme und Prostatik.
Ich habe die Prostatik mit einem Gewichtabnahme gesagt.
Welche Therapie haben Sie erst begonnen?
Die Therapie besteht in der Entfernung des betroffenen Gewebes, der Prostatdose und zugehörigen Lymphknoten.
Eine Entschuldigung kann sein, oder?
Ich werde eine Urinprobe durchführen.
Ich werde die Entzündungswerte überprüfen.
Wenn er eine Entzündung oder Prostatik hat, werde ich eine Antibiotik und Therapie verabreichen.
Ich werde eine Blutkultur für diese Patienten abnehmen.
Wenn er Fieber hat, werde ich eine Blutkultur und Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wie unterscheiden Sie sich zwischen Akutapiolenephritis und Akutaprostatitis?
Akutapiolenephritis erwarten wir die Schmerzen im ländlichen Plankenbereich.
Wir können eine Prostatflüssigkeit entnehmen.
Prostatflüssigkeit entnehmen.
Das ist eine Prostatflüssigkeit.
Möchten Sie diese Patienten durchführen?
Eine CT ist ein Symbol.
Können Sie uns die Computer Tomographie erklären?
Die Computer Tomographie ist eine bildgebende Methode.
Mit der können wir Organe, Gewebe und Knochen beurteilen.
Mit Hilfe von Röntgenstrahlung.
Es enthält Röntgenstrahlung, aber nicht enorm.
Vor der Untersuchung sollten Sie nicht vorbereiten.
Nach der Untersuchung können Sie Ihr gewohntes Leben vorsetzen.
Das ist eine Schmerzfreie Untersuchung.
Sie liegen ein Licht.
Der Licht bewegt sich in einer ringformigen Maschine.
Wenn Sie Angst haben, können Sie mir eine Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Das ist alles.
Hat der Patient Angst vor Prostatkarsenome?
Ja, sein Vater ist an Prostatkarsenome verstorben.
Sie leidet an der Suri und schmissen Lücken.
Er hat Angst davor.
Hat der Patient Geschwister?
Er hat zwei Geschwister, aber keinen Kontakt mit ihnen.
Gibt es andere Fragen?
Ja, um meine Verdachtstheorie zu bestätigen, würde ich eine Prostatebiopsie durchführen.
Bei histologischen Untersuchungen können wir diese Krankheit diagnostizieren.
Wie?
Unter Ultraschall.
Jetzt oder nach der Infektion?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist genug für uns.
Guten Abend Herr Prost. Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Natürlich, bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Josef Meister.
Er ist 72 Jahre alt, 1,68 Meter groß und 59 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei bis fünf Monaten bestehender, dauerhafter, dumpfer, steckender Durchsalge ohne Strahlung vor.
Der Patient hat die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und wurde in der Zeit schlimmer.
Er erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen bei Bewegung schlimmer werden.
Er klagt über Fatigue, Nektorie, Dysurie und Dunkelurin wie Hematurie.
Außerdem gibt er an, dass er abgeschwachte und gespaltene Harnstatt und sowie das gefühlte Restharnbildung bemägt habe.
Der Patient hat deswegen bei ihrem Arzt viele Mal gewesen.
Der Hausarzt hat ihm gesagt, dass es normal ist.
Die Einnahme von Ibuprofen 600 Milligramm hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Gewichtabnahme von 10 Kilogramm innerhalb von sechs Monaten.
Die Frage nach Hautfarbeveränderung, Yucrease, Noise und Emesis wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Pyrexie und Insomnik.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit zehn Jahren arteriöse, bestehende arteriöse Hypertonik
und 25 Jahren bestehende chronische Obstruktur Lungenerkrankungen.
Er wurde nicht operiert.
Im Besuch auf Medikation nimmt er 5 Milligramm Delix einmal täglich an.
Er nimmt deswegen chronische Obstruktur Lungenerkrankungen, einen Spray an.
Aber die Anamnese sollte in der Werkstatt geklaut werden.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Er rauchte seit 40 Jahren zwei Schachter Zigaretten.
Er trinkte zwei bis drei Mal Provaque, ein Glas Wein oder eine Flasche Bier,
und hat Drogenkonsum würde verneint.
Im Besuch auf Familienanamnese teilt er mit, dass der Vater an Magen-Karsenom
mit 65 Jahren gestorben ist.
Und der Vater mit 85 Jahren an Prostat-Karsenoma verstorben.
Der Vater hatte arteriöse Hypertonik, die Mutter hatte Diabetes mellitus.
Er hatte zwei Geschwister, aber er hatte keinen Kontakt.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Der Patient ist verheiratet und hat drei Kinder.
Die Kinder sind gesund.
Er ist jetzt Rentner.
Er hat früher als Taxifahrer gearbeitet.
Er wohnt mit seiner Frau.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Prostat-Karsenoma aus.
Der Patient hat typische Symptome.
Der Patient leidet unter Niktur, Dysur und Hematur.
Außerdem hat der Patient schwache Harnstalle und das Gefühl der Resteharnbildung bemerkt.
Diese Symptome sprechen für Prostat-Karsenoma.
Außerdem gibt es sehr wichtige Symptome wie Gewichtabnahme.
Außerdem hat er viele Risikofaktoren.
Der Vater ist an Prostat-Karsenoma verstorben.
Er ist altem.
Diese Risikofaktoren sind sehr wichtig für Prostat-Karsenoma.
Die Rücken schmerzen.
Das ist nicht typisch für Prostat-Karsenoma.
Aber ich denke, das ist eine Methastase.
Prostat-Karsenoma ist über Knöcken.
Was würden Sie durchführen, um diese Situation aufzuschließen?
Ich meine eine Methastase.
Ich würde eine Synthographie durchführen, um eine Methastase zu schließen.
Zuerst?
Zuerst würde ich die Stete des Abdomens durchführen.
Vor der Stete?
Vor der Stete würde ich das Symbol eines Röntgenknöckens durchführen.
Sie haben recht.
Machen Sie sich bitte weiter.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
kommen die Differenzialdiagnose Prostat-Hypertrophy und Pylonephritis,
Divertikulitis in Betracht.
Warum denken Sie Divertikulitis?
Der Patient, ja, es ist nicht Symbol.
Warum denken Sie so?
Der Patient hat lange Geflügel, Rücken Schmerzen, aber der Patient hat Bauchschmerzen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Divertikulitis?
Verstopfung, Obstipation und Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen.
Und vielleicht manchmal Fieber.
An welcher Seite war Sie eine Bauchschmerzen?
An der linken Seite, besonders an der linken Seite.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst den Patienten die Pferdbetalparameter überwachen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Welche Parameter würden Sie kontrollieren?
Fieber, weil der Patient Fieber und Präzise nicht gemessen hat.
Zunächst werde ich das Fieber messen.
Dann wird der Patient vielleicht abtasten.
Wenn der Patient wegen Karsinoma anhängt, gibt es mögliche schnellere Pulse.
Der Patient hat auch arteriale Hypertonik.
Ich werde den Patienten Blutdruck messen.
Blutdruck?
Blutdruck messen, ja.
Welche Besymptome hat der Patient?
Der Patient hat Stülpfrost, Nackschweiß, Gewichtabnahme und Fieber.
Das Symptom spricht für Wettsymptome.
Okay, machen Sie weiter.
Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Abwärtsschäden, Loslassschmerzen und Druckschmerzen.
Warum? Hat der Patient Bauchschmerzen? Warum kontrollieren Sie diese Symptome?
Der Patient hat keine Bauchschmerzen, aber es ist möglich, irgendwelche Bauchprobleme auszuschließen.
Ich werde Bauch palpieren.
Wie zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel, Sie haben gesagt, Divertikulitis. Es ist möglich, ja.
Okay.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich den Patienten digital und rektal untersuchen.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ich würde dabei die Kontur, die Größe und die Konsistenz der Prostate beurteilen.
Das ist sehr besonders für den Patienten.
Neben den körperlichen Untersuchungen, werden die Laborunterzüge ein Symbol für die Diagnostik verwendet.
Dabei werde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, CRP, BSG und Prostate, spezifisch Antigen, PSA bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich Urin-Test und Urin-Kultur durchführen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten Ultraschall, Abdomanzonographie durchführen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten Trans-rektal-Zonographie durchführen.
Dann werde ich die Prostate-Probleme genau erkennen.
Zonographie durchführen und mögliche Prostate Probleme genau erkennen.
Ok, könntest du bitte Transrectal Zonographie erklären?
Ja, Transrectal Zonographie ist eine spezielle Unterzuchtung mit Ultra-Charbeln.
Dabei werden wir durch ein kleines Ultra-Charbel durchführen.
Und wir werden mit dem Ultra-Charbel eine Form von Prostate machen.
Das ist eine Schmerzlosunterzuchtung, aber es ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Vor der Unterzuchtung sollte der Patient seine Plätze entwerfen.
Nach der Unterzuchtung gibt es keine bestimmten Bein-Schränkungen.
Man sollte die alte Wiggewand fortsetzen.
Es gibt keine bestimmten Kontrastmittel.
Es gibt keine bestimmten Kontraste.
Manche Fallen können stattdessen andere Unterzuchtungsmethoden wie CTDs, Abdomen oder andere.
Aber es ist abhängig von den Krankbildern.
Wie würden Sie diesen Patienten behandeln? Stationär oder abgeladen?
Der Patient hat jetzt Fieber und viel Angst.
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich werde ihm einen Beneszugang vorlegen und eine Flüssigkeit zuvor und Analgetika und gegebenenfalls Antibiotika verabreichen.
Ich werde den Patienten eine urologische Konzil anordnen, um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Ich denke, die wichtige Therapie ist eine chirurgische, vielleicht eine mikrochirurgische Operation.
Aber es ist abhängig vom Stadium des Tumors.
Okay. Gut, vielen Dank, meine Kollegen.
Danke, Herr Oberhausen.